okay
okay
slow
oh
thank you
yes
[Music]
oh yeah
getting chilly
earlier
two minute warning for the briefing two
minute warning for the briefing
thank you
yes
um
yep
everyone
okay uh today uh the president will
announce
that on thursday he expects he will meet
his goal of 200 million
shots administered in 100 days or under
100 days i should say
a goal he doubled after meeting his
original goal of 100 million shots by
day 58
of his presidency as the administration
as we work
to get even more people vaccinated
president biden will call on employers
across america to do everything they can
to help their employees
and their communities get vaccinated
that includes a tax credit
for small and medium-sized businesses to
fully offset the cost of paid leave for
employees to get vaccinated
and recover from any after effects of
vaccination if needed
and a call for employers large and small
to take additional steps to help get
their employees and communities
vaccinated with that i wanted to kick us
off
um doj announced a pattern of practice
investigation today the
minneapolis pd uh an aftermath of the
george
floyd killing and verdict under current
law um it's a high bar
uh for convicting officers of federal
civil rights crimes
does the president think it's time to
revisit this aspect of the law
well first as the president alluded to
last night in his remarks
after the verdict was announced he
believes the bar for convicting officers
is far too high
it needs to be changed uh he's a strong
supporter as he also
conveyed passionately last night of the
george floyd
justice in policing act which does
change the intent standard obviously
there is
negotiations that need to happen on
capitol hill but uh he believes the bar
is too high that includes the
uh federal civil rights aspect of the
law as well
um or speaking my understanding is
that's also addressed in the bill
okay and in a second if i could just get
on briefly um
he's obviously going to be meeting with
world leaders today on the climate
summit
what does he say to lay concerns
considering how divided
um washington is politically on this
issue that
we're actually going to uh but this
country's gonna follow through on what
he says today
what he says this week well i think what
he's sending the message he's sending to
the country and frankly to the world
is that he feels that the climate crisis
we're facing uh around the world and
certainly in this country as the world's
largest emitters
is so significant that under within a
hundred days of his
presidency he's convening the world's
largest economies to have a discussion
about that
and he is going to uh put um put actions
in place as well obviously he's put in
place a number of executive actions
and he'll announce we'll have more
specifics to announce in the coming days
about
what targets we're setting here in the
united states and i understand what
you're asking me as
what happens in 2024 right or is that
what you're asking me
well that's a long time away but the
president has every intention of getting
reelected
and certainly ensuring uh that he is
implementing policies where
uh climate addressing our climate crisis
putting americans back to work
go hand in hand which is absolutely his
desire and his commitment
will be a part of his continuing agenda
thank you jen you just called on
congress to pass the george floyd bill
president vice president harris did the
same last night
said it's a key priority why should
people have
confidence that president bottom will be
able to win over
republican support for the george floyd
bill when he hasn't been able to do so
on his other legislative priorities
like the american rescue plan that he
passed into law
he didn't get republican support for
that he didn't but he certainly has
support from the american people
and about 80 percent of almost more than
70 percent of the american people
i will say christine that look the
president doesn't believe that
he he alone can pull the george floyd
act policing act across the finish line
that is going to be up to congress and
right now
there are negotiations that are
happening there are leaders in both
sides that are having
those discussions uh the president
obviously advocated as you alluded to
last night and remarks he delivered
after the verdict um and we are also uh
have been advocating our senior
leadership has been advocating for this
on the hill
including in direct conversations with
members we're in close touch with the
senate judiciary committee senate
leadership
who are working towards this goal this
encompasses many offices in the white
house including
of course the president talked about
this quite a bit during his meeting with
the cbc last week but also our
legislative affairs team our public
engagement team
the department of the domestic policy
council and their leaders are deeply
engaged and we're also in regular
contact with the nation's civil rights
leaders who were also
advocating for this but i will also say
that there are times and this is true in
diplomacy but also true in legislating
that we need the best strategy is to
provide the space for those
conversations to happen
privately and that's our part of our
objective
i understand you're citing the fact that
public polling showed
there was bipartisan support for arp but
in order to get the george
floyd bill passed you need 60 votes
so i guess the question is why should
people have faith that the president
will be able to get 60 votes to get the
george floyd bill passed
well i think what i was trying to convey
but let me try again is that
the president alone cannot pass the
george floyd
policing justice and policing act into
law how does he see his role in getting
the george floydville pass well
his role is to work with leaders in
congress as he did
as he has being in touch with leaders in
congress in the senate and house also
having a discussion with members of the
congressional black caucus many of whom
are playing
important and prominent roles in getting
this legislation across
the finish line art he's also asked
members of his
senior team whether it's the legislative
team domestic policy council
his office of public engagement to work
with outside organizations
civil rights leaders and others to uh
to work together to put pressure on
congress to move forward
he used the opportunity last night to
deliver remarks and i will say is he's
preparing to as he's thinking about what
his
joint session speech looks like next
week uh he has every intention of losing
using that as an opportunity to elevate
this issue and talk about the importance
of putting police reform
measures in place you know one of the
key sticking points is that qualified
immunity provision is the president
willing to compromise on qualified
immunity would he
back a bill that didn't include
qualified community well again i think
the stage we're in now is that leaders
on the hill need to have discussions
among themselves about where they can
find
agreement and often those discussions
just like they do it is the case in
diplomacy
uh the best strategy the most effective
strategy is to allow for space for those
conversations to have
be happen privately once they once they
come to agreement and we're certainly
hopeful they'll do that we'll have to
take a look at what that looks like
oh go ahead what do you mean just to
follow up from the other person's line
of questions sure
kristen's in the front row
when president biden spoke with george
floyd's family yesterday he promised
that he would do everything he could to
get
the george floyd justice and policing
act passed so
would that potentially include
supporting getting rid of the filibuster
if you can't
get the 60 votes needed to pass the
senate the president's view remains the
same
which is that he believes there should
be support from democrats and
republicans
to put in place uh common sense long
overdue
measures to reform our police and
justice system
and he believes rebuilding trust among
communities is something that democrats
and republicans should support
there are conversations that are
happening now that involve democrats and
republicans and he wants to leave the
space for that
so he doesn't believe that having a
discussion about the filibuster is
constructive to that at this point
okay and two questions on immigration is
president biden
potentially open to doing immigration
reform through reconciliation
well um this is another area where the
president
looks both at history and also you know
past history and also recent history and
sees that there
has been bipartisan sport there is
bipartisan support for example on the
dreamers and moving forward there
and he believes that modernizing our
immigration system
uh and putting in measures in place to
address that is something that
should warrant bipartisan support so his
view
is that right now this should not be
that the conversation should not be
about
a reconciliation process it should be
about moving forward in a bipartisan
manner
and so i mean these members of the
congressional hispanic office that
president biden met with yesterday
they said that we need to find any other
foreign avenue
to achieve as much as we can and that
can include reconciliation so i guess
can you at least confirm that that did
indeed come up during their meeting
members of congress raised this issue
they were saying that president biden
raised this issue and that he at least
expressed some degree of support for it
uh well i guess i can articulate what
the president's point of view is and
certainly what his intention of
conveying in any private meeting was
which is that he believes there should
be bipartisan support
of course members are going to propose a
range of mechanics for moving things
forward
but his view is that the conversation
right now should be uh should not be
focused on reconciliation should we
focus on finding a bipartisan path
forward
go ahead thanks you mentioned
republicans and democrats negotiating
this on capitol hill
um is it immigration is on my head in my
mind no no it's okay
i just wanted to make sure it's the
answering the right question on the
george floyd
um or this issue of police reform
is there is is does this white house see
this as
the george floyd act all or nothing is
there
room for republican proposals like the
one from
senator tim scott of course this is this
is going to be a discussion and
a lot of the conversations right now as
you know from covering this are
happening between democrats
like senator cory booker and like
senator tim scott
and they're going to have to decide
where they can find agreement moving
forward
ultimately the president believes as he
conveyed quite passionately last night
that we need to put in place police
reform measures
they're long overdue uh and uh certainly
the events of the last few weeks
uh elevate this as an issue we should be
adjust
adapting or not adapting to we should be
addressing as a society
so we know that democracy in action
means there are negotiations there's
compromise we'll see what that looks
like
but our objective here is to stay in
close touch uh through senior members of
our white house team through the
president himself
to be helpful and constructive and good
feedback as needed but also to leave
space for those conversations to happen
did you mention the negotiations on the
hill as a separate entity from
from this white house will could you
just elaborate on what you just said the
president's involved in senior stats
involvement
we've seen the president get involved in
negotiations on infrastructure on coped
really will he get involved in something
like police reform he he had a high
level conversation with members of the
congressional black caucus just last
week
and this was a prominent part an
important part of that conversation
and i wasn't intending to send so i
appreciate you asking i wasn't intending
to convey that it was separate it's not
separate
but there are conversations that are
happening between democrats and
republicans on capitol hill
we are staying abreast of those we are
certainly engaged
with a number of those members at a
range of levels in this white house
including at the
president's level but also from leaders
in the legislative team from leaders of
his
office of public engagement and from
leaders from of the domestic policy
council
i have a deadline by which he would like
to see this on his desk given
where this falls in the national
discourse right now and the importance
and the potential for
losing the momentum that exists well i
think the president certainly sees
this moment as an opportunity to
redouble everyone's efforts in getting
this legislation
passed and move forward uh but he also
recognizes having served 36 years in the
senate
that you can't rush negotiations between
democrats
and republicans um he's eager to have
something on his
desk but uh we're not here to set a
deadline at this point in time
um go ahead thanks jen um i know we're
celebrating 200 million shots today but
there's
some indications that uh at the very
least
rates aren't written at the same rate as
they have been previous in the
administration the rates of vaccination
or sorry
just clarify which means being put in
arms and and
my question is whether you guys see that
as
just sort of the inevitable lift from j
coming out of circulation
if it's um hitting a wall
we're now moving towards folks who might
be more hesitant to get vaccine versus
folks who already have if it's just sort
of
um splits in the data or if
you don't basically if you don't think
that the last few days have been
representative of a broader trend
um and more broadly i know that you or
the president is planning to announce
this
uh tax break going into effect but
are there other things that you can talk
about the administration doing to
address hesitancies
that now seem to be squarely pivoting
away from folks who are eager to get the
vaccine and towards folks who are not
well first i would say and and you asked
a few questions there let me see if i
can answer all of them
um what we've seen and there was some
interesting data that came out over the
last couple of days obviously a lot was
happening yesterday is that um we've
actually seen
a decrease in hesitancy and increasing
confidence among
many communities so uh in some polling
that was put out
just yesterday 40 percent of respondents
said they were more likely to get the
cov19 vaccine than they were a month ago
and as a full in terms of conservatives
confidence in vaccine again this is a
poll so it's not perfect but it was
interesting data
a full 71 percent of trump voters said
they have either received at least one
dose of a vaccine
or definitely or probably will up from
59 in an earlier poll conducted just one
month ago
so what we're trying to address to
answer another one of your questions is
what we see is the issues the barriers
to
uh getting the majority of the american
people vaccinated and one of those
barriers is access and so what the
uh announcement today was is intended to
do is
address one of those barriers to access
which is people
of not not through a political prism uh
but
many people who have not yet been
vaccinated or concerned they can't take
a day off of work
uh they don't have additional paid leave
and so we're trying to address that
barrier
reduce that barrier as a one that is
preventing
access i will say that the reason we're
at this point where we are getting to a
point which we always knew we would
reach
where we have greater supply we will at
a point get to a point where we have
greater supply than we have demand
is because in in so only in some regions
of the country i should say as you know
not everywhere is because we work
quickly to increase supply
and provide thousands of easy and
convenient locations for people to get
vaccinated so
you know in the last few weeks we've
send out more than 115 million doses
but what we're trying to do now uh is
address
what we see as the barrier so i
mentioned the the um
tax cut of course trying to help
businesses uh we're providing technical
assistance to states
again we're relying on local voices and
local doctors to provide the best
information which
every set of data we've seen and even
from some news organizations show that
those are the most trusted
messengers we've allocated three billion
dollars to states we're ramping up
targeted
media efforts we're also along with the
cdc we're working to help
states expand vaccine distribution to
primary care physicians where many
people are very much
trusted local doctors so yes we will
continue to assess and look for ways to
uh increase access and get it out to
more communities no
both the washington post and new york
times last night had pretty
uh detailed reports about the refugee
issue um they suggested the president
himself overruled uh national security
experts on his team and secretary of
state lincoln
um you've sort of maintained that there
was never a policy change at all but
is it fair to say at this point that the
president um
changed his mind from the 62 500 number
and then changed his mind again once he
saw the sort of
outrage outrage and blowback from
from democrats and refugee groups
well i can say that we have every
intention of putting out
in an increased cap and we hope to do
that soon in advance of may 15th
i'm obviously not going to get into
private conversations between the
president and
members of his national security team
but i will say that
one of the things that that has been on
the president's mind that i think was
covered in a number of those stories
are the challenges um and the challenges
to our resources and we've talked about
this a little bit
so one of those is refugee processing in
a global big global system
and there were muscles that have been
atrophied over the last few years it's
not just the federal government
it is also a lot of important
organizations around the world that help
address this
and his concern was in part is that
system prepared
now by setting a larger cap which we
have every intention of doing
we are sending a message get your
muscles back in action
uh so that we can welcome more refugees
and continue to
uh strive toward the goal that he has
always maintained of 125
000 refugees for next year our policy
has not changed on that front we've
always wanted to reach 125. it's just a
matter of what we think we can get to
this year
the state department is in charge of
processing refugees
the secretary of state is encouraging
the president to
sign the paperwork to raise the cap that
would suggest that he feels
the state department despite whatever
after feeding may have
happened could have raised that limit
and that the president because of
perhaps you know worries about if hhs
could support the refugees when they got
there
perhaps because of political
calculations overruled
the secretary of state and so i'm asking
if you can explain
why if the state department says that
they can do this the president didn't
think that they could
well first of all it's setting a cap
right it doesn't answer the question of
whether we can reach that
this is an important point of whether we
can reach that point
to get into this right because there's
no reason that the president couldn't
have done what he said he was going to
do
and then if the state department or hhs
determined that they couldn't
you know process the refugees just not
hit that number as you said yesterday or
two days ago
that happens all the time so sure this
just sort of and he has every
and he has ever and he has every
intention of raising
the cap the friday announcement was not
about the high top level of the cap
um and i think that's an important
it's an important thing for people to
understand but i'd also say as you two
in your question
the state department yes they do the
visa pro
they do the vetting which is an
important part of the process and can
take
months and there are a low number of
refugees that are currently through a
security vetting process despite numbers
that have been put out there and in
reporting which are inaccurate
there's a low number what'd you say
there's not hundreds of people that had
already been approved by the state
department
i think the reports are something like
700 people have had to cancel flights
because of
and the flights are resumed the flights
has resumed as of friday
but there's also another component of
this because it's an interagency process
that addresses refugees for settlement
right
orr the office of refugee resettlement
which is not a part of the state
department
has a component of this as well it's a
part of hhs president looks at
all of the government all of our
resources available what he thinks the
capacity is
but he also is looking for assessments
from the interagency team on what's
possible
that's what his questions were hence
we'll have more to say when we have a
conclusion on that
i think we're talking past each other so
i'll just ask once more and then we okay
but the question is whether the
president
changed his policy on the 6500 and
if on friday you intended it to be 15
000 and
you changed the change to the decision
after the outcome
well his policy was was on friday
was months before continues to be to
reach 125 000 refugees
in next fiscal year 625 was a down
payment
it will be slower this year than it will
be next year the president wants an
assessment of how far
we can get that's what he's looking for
the state department has a component of
that hhs is a component of that
we're going to look at all of that and
the refugee cap and the point i've been
trying to make which i know you don't
love but that's okay
but to others is that the cap is
something that is not typically reached
we wanted to send a clear message we are
a country that is welcoming
refugees we recognize that that is not
the message that was sent
and so we reassessed but it's not a
change in policy it's just
making sure we're sending a clear
message to the world about who we are
america's back
we're welcoming refugees we need to get
our muscles back
working again and and we'll have an uh
an updated cap uh hopefully soon go
ahead trevor
the point about kind of getting the
muscles back to where you
need to be um you know we're curious
just about what capacity does exist
right now
for the government and when you talk
about the office of refugee resettlement
is one of the issues that some of the
employees there have been
transferred over to dealing with some of
the asylum issues is that
is that one one potential issue there
well
one of the issues the president wanted
once wanted an assessment of whether
they could do both
right it's there are components that
exist in different agencies of
government
right but whether they could do both
whether there was enough funding to do
both there has been funding transferred
from
other components of hhs to help address
the unaccompanied uh
children of refugee resettlement uh
during the last administration
and there were only a couple thousand
low number of thousand refugees who are
welcomed in
during the last fiscal year so it's not
just
government it's also external
organizations who play a vital role
and certainly and this is one of the
points i think maybe we were in
agreement but i think you were getting
to
or what i was trying to get to is that
it's also these high caps the 125 cap
is sending a message to the world we are
going to do this
work with us on this work with us on
vetting work with us on resettling
and assistance that's needed there are
legal requirements and funding
requirements that we need to help
refugees when they come into the country
from orr there's funding requirements
for that but we also acknowledge a lot
of the funding comes from outside
organizations
that needs to be prepared as well
there's one other factor we haven't
talked about but
is an interesting one i think is there
are some some limitations that have come
about because of covet because
sometimes typically in the past people
have traveled to do some of these
vetting interviews and
expedite moving refugees through
processing also
people coming into um embassies around
the world
that's an additional challenge we were
looking at assessment of all of these of
all of these items
do you have a number just of how many
refugee officers have been transferred
over to dealing with
asylum or unaccompanied minor issues uh
transferred over from uads or
transferred over who work in the office
of
refugee resettlement as officers but now
they're working primarily on
unaccompanied children uh we have some
funding numbers i don't think i have
staff numbers in front of me i'd
certainly
send you to them but we can check if
there's more specifics and
are there outstanding security concerns
around the refugee resettlement program
that are being addressed as part of this
um review that you're doing well there's
a fairly stringent vetting process that
takes place
um and that can take months and months
it really depends uh
there have been some limitations and
delays frankly because of kovid which
has happened in other areas
as well i'm not saying that's the
totality but that is certainly a factor
uh but that can certainly take some time
so that's had an impact as well
okay but not new security is cons issues
if that was what you were asking
um and then just on policing uh just
quickly just
curious that we were talking about the
doj announcement this morning
is there any white house reaction on uh
on that
decision to start that investigation and
has there been any other
outreach that you've done to police
groups or civil rights groups
since the floyd verdict as you move
forward
sure well let me first say that um
during the campaign the president
pledged to appoint doj leadership
that would prioritize pattern or
practice investigations and so last week
obviously we didn't know the outcome
right of the verdict but just to give a
little history here
last week the attorney general reversed
a trump administration memo that limited
the use of consent decrees
with respect to investigation of police
departments and obviously while we
didn't know what the announcement would
be today
uh the attorney the announcement today
of this new investigation into policing
policies in minnesota
there's kind of a direct pattern right
there of the what the president was
advocating for
who he nominated the overturning of the
memo uh just last week
uh go ahead again um one on vaccines one
in russia
sure what does the vitamin divide the
administration consider to be
vaccine discrimination should public or
private spaces
be allowed to exclude people out of
getting a coconut connection
i don't think those are standards we're
setting from here obviously private
sector businesses and entities are going
to set their own standards
you mentioned earlier you'd be releasing
guidance on the privacy
rights people can expect when it comes
to a vaccination
are you referring to like an faq related
to vaccine passports
or something part of that yeah okay well
i think
just to be clear on the vaccine passport
issue what we also made clear is that
that's not something that is going to be
um conducted
reviewed or overseen by the federal
government
on russia today in his annual address
russian president vladimir putin warned
against foreign intervention
in ukraine where there is a
troop buildup reported in parts of
crimea and hundreds of protesters
supporting
alexey navalny have been arrested is
there evidence that the white house sees
that u.s sanctions against russia are
working
well first um our sanctions were put in
place and
many of them uh done in coordination
with our european partners and allies
because our strong view in the view of
the global community is that there
should be consequences for actions
we have never expected nor have we
projected
that one set of sanctions or any
individual set of sanctions is going to
immediately change behavior but it is
sending a clear message
that behavior is unacceptable and it
can't continue i would also remind you
that
uh our consequences as we've long said
many are seen
sanctions and some are unseen and we
don't speak about more specifically
uh go ahead thank you very much uh two
two more foreign ones
um today uh australia announced it was
the australian federal government was
revoking a deal by one of the states
to do a belt and road initiative with uh
china chinese
um has the administration administration
talk specifically with australia about
that
deal and more generally is the
administration talking with its allies
and partners around the world about the
pri
and generally kind of get get fans to
push back against that
uh i think the state department would be
the most likely entity within government
to give any readout of conversations
about the australians
obviously economic partnerships
relationships uh how we can work
together as a global community
and in a coordinated fashion as it
relates to china is
part of nearly every discussion the
president has with a european partner or
a country in the region
specifically the belt initiative which
obviously has been
painted by summers this kind of you know
very
clever soft power slash lunch shark
scheme taking over a large part of the
world but what's the us
well what about it is your question well
i mean given that australia today pushed
back against this very specifically i
was just wondering if the us is in like
having actual
you know direct talks with partners
about you know we've got to do something
about this bri
i can check and see if there's anything
more specific okay
and the other one is um uh the
president and putin as well today
both are touting this uh supposed plan
by the us to try to assassinate
lukashenko belarus
i can confirm there's no basis in fact
there uh go ahead
i just want to bring it back to policing
on a call with george boyce family
and the family's attorney after the
verdict yesterday uh
the family attorney said quote hopefully
this is the momentum for the georgia
justice and policing act to get passed
and have you signed
the president's response was you got it
all that a lot more
not just that but a lot more so when
your estimation is that the president
promising to the floyd family that
he will get a policing bill passed i
think he's promising to the floyd family
that he will use the power of his
presidency the bully pulpit as he
intends to do during this joint address
next week
uh the role of senior leaders in his
government
to help push the george floyd police and
justice and policing act
how far is he willing to push for it i'm
not sure what that means
i mean how far is he willing to push to
get something done
in what way you just talked about um
giving
people in congress lawmakers breathing
room to talk and negotiate
but you know how far is he what is he
willing to get democrats online
is he willing to keep just pushing for
this is it
a huge fire like can you prioritize or
give me a sense of his priorities
in terms of getting this done well i
would point you to the fact that one the
president gave a passionate
uh call last night for the importance of
moving forward in this moment
with the george floyd justice and
policing act uh
it is on his mind as he is working with
his team
and all of us to draft his joint session
speech which is one of the highest
profile moments
any president has in the first year of
their presidency uh
he has worked and has just had
discussions with leaders and members of
congress
about moving forward on the george
justice and policing act including
as recently as his meeting with the
congressional black caucus
last week and he has asked prominent
leading members of his
administration to uh remain closely
involved and engaged in this effort as
it moves forward so i'd say it's
absolutely priority on his mind and he
feels this is a moment
where there should be momentum for
action on putin who today did have some
aggressive language for western nations
that would
you know interfere in russia's affairs
he said that russia's responsible
asymmetric fast and tough if forced to
defend
its interests i'm just wondering broadly
and the russians have also expressed
skepticism that
sanctions could do anything to box them
into uh
to having a summit between putin and the
president can you give us any
update on how putin's words today and
his posture
uh could affect any plans for his summit
between the two
well um we've been clear um that we
desire a relationship with russia that
is stable
and predictable and we don't think it
needs to be continue to be on a negative
trajectory
the sanctions were not meant to entice
anyone to attend a summit that would be
a strange strategy
it was meant to uh put in place
consequences for
the actions that were completely
unacceptable
in our eyes and the eyes of the global
community at the same time
while we put those consequences in place
the president was sending a clear
message to president putin on his call
that he believes we can have uh
this is an opportunity to have a
discussion about areas where we think
there's an opportunity to work together
on
uh whether that is nuclear
non-proliferation proliferation
as we did with the continuation the
extension of the new start treaty
or the iran nuclear deal and also have
discussions about errors where we
disagree
obviously it requires uh all parties
having an agreement that we're going to
have a meeting and we issued that
invitation we're continuing to have
discussions at
a high level as as is evidenced by the
national security advisers
conversation with his counterpart
earlier this week go ahead
i'll come back to it thank you thank you
jenna a quick
quick follow-up question on something
you asked yesterday and then a second
somewhat related question
okay um regarding yesterday um i
respectfully i i feel like you didn't
get quite firm answer and i wanted to
try again okay you were asked whether
president biden will honor his
democratic primary campaign pledge to
release quote
everyone in prison for marijuana uh
people are skeptical that he will
president biden is personally
responsible for sending some people to
prison for life for marijuana under his
1994 crime bill
and vice president kamala harris oversaw
1900 marijuana convictions san francisco
district attorney so will president
bonner will president biden honor his
commitment
to release ever in prison for marijuana
well i think what i did yesterday is
reiterated what his position on
marijuana was
decriminalizing or rescheduling um and
certainly legalizing medical marijuana
what you're asking me is a legal
question and now we're in government and
so
i had to follow up with our legal team
and i don't have any additional
information quite yet regarding
rescheduling that wouldn't necessarily
release anyone from prison schedule 2 as
has fentanyl and cocaine
that's right it addresses things moving
forward though which is important and
important to many advocates
should people in prison for marijuana
who are asking president biden to honor
his pledge to release them should they
expect to be released
or are they going to serve life in
prison for marijuana well again i think
i've
stated very clearly what the president's
position is what you're asking me is a
legal question i'd point you to the
department of justice and if there's
anything more we can provide from here
i'm happy to provide it
second question uh president biden
yesterday uh responding to george
the george flor floyd case verdict said
that george floyd's death quote ripped
the blinders off for the whole world to
see the systemic racism in the united
states
but he's an architect of multiple
federal laws in the 1980s and 90s
that disproportionately jailed black
people and contributed to what many
people see as systemic racism
uh activist cornell west said that biden
was quote one of the core architects of
mass incarceration
and that quote i think biden is going to
have to take responsibility and then
acknowledge the contribution he made
mass incarceration
uh to what extent does president biden
acknowledge his own role in uh
systemic racism and how does that inform
his current policy positions
well i would say that the president's
one of the
president's core objectives is
addressing racial injustice in this
country
not just through his rhetoric but
through his actions and what anyone
should look to
is his advocacy for passing the george
floyd justice and policing act
for nominating leaders to the department
of justice to
address uh long outdated um
policies uh and to uh ask his team
leadership team here in the white house
to prioritize these issues in his
presidency which is current end of the
day and not from 30 years ago
believe it's important to accept his own
culpability i think that answered your
question
go ahead questions um you kind of
touched on the first one but
let me repeat today criticize the west
by saying that all provocateurs will
regret it more than ever he compared
european countries with jackals who
quote unquote
how to their shirt on but does uh did
not name specific
name names or countries does the u.s
take it personally
i don't think we take uh anything
president putin says personally we have
tough skin
and then the second question is on
february 2nd assistant immigration
uh bite inside an executive order
calling for uh the cdc and homeland
security to review title 242
i'm wondering if there's any update on
that review
title 42 is still in place uh because we
are
still in the midst of fighting a global
pandemic um
so i don't have any uh predictions of
one that will change
uh go ahead all right then taylor
poplars with spectrum news three quick
questions i'll make them quick um
first has the president been briefed on
16 year old makaya bryant being shot and
killed by police in columbus ohio
yesterday it happened
moments before the show converted came
out yes
um i said
yes and let me let me just say since you
gave me the opportunity
uh the killing of sixteen-year-old
michaela bryant by the columbus police
is tragic
she was a child we're thinking of her
friends and family in the communities
that are hurting and grieving her loss
we know that police violence just
proportionally impacts
black and latino people and communities
in that black women and girls like black
men and boys
experience higher rates of police
violence we also know that
there are particular vulnerabilities
that children in foster care
care like mccain face and her death came
as you noted just as america was hopeful
of a step forward after the traumatic
and exhausting trial of derek chovin
and the verdict that was reached so our
focus is
on um working to address systemic racism
and implicit implicit bias head-on and
of course to
passing laws and legislation that will
put much-needed reforms
into place at police departments around
the country has the president
briefed on it yes okay and then also in
ohio the family of tamir rice the
12-year-old cleveland boy who was killed
by police in 2014.
they've asked the justice department to
reopen his case does the president
support that
i would appoint the department of
justice and then lastly a climate
related question there have been several
lawmakers from ohio and other states who
have called for the u.s postal service
vehicle contract
to be paused with oshkosh defense the
lawmakers are alleging that
there was maybe inappropriate political
dealing with it but also that it may not
meet up to the president's executive
order
on electrifying the fleet okay is the
white house concerned about that do they
agree do you agree with the pause and
investigation
i'll have to check on that it's an
interesting question so just to
understand
it is about a contract that a company
has that may or may not meet the
electric fleet
objectives in the executive order yeah
the postal service has said they'll
at least be able to electrify 10 but
obviously the president just wanted to
electrify
the whole fleet yes okay let me check on
that for you uh go ahead
thanks chad i've got one on uh anti-aap
discrimination and i'd like to circle
back on a vaccine question
let's start with the vaccines um a
number of lawmakers
democratic lawmakers in foreign
countries have asked the president
to waive vaccine patents to surge
production
what possible reason could the president
have for not doing this
given that a number of organizations
like doctors without orders and oxfam
have said that this would be integral to
the global fight against coronavirus
outside of protecting the you know
financial interests of these
pharmaceutical companies or maybe
maintaining leverage over you know
production of the vaccine
uh entirely is there any reason why you
wouldn't do this
well i think um our ambassador our ustr
ambassador gave some remarks related to
this
uh just last weekend and i'd certainly
point you to those and we're certainly
looking at a range of options to help
address the global pandemic but i don't
have anything more from here
then on anti-aapi hate will the
president directs
uh miss moritzugu to investigate claims
of
uh discrimination from that community uh
in the college admissions process
the um executive orders he took in march
or he signed in march
notably didn't address this and then the
doj
actually dropped federal lawsuit um you
know supporting that claim
in february well it's her first week on
the job
um she just started um and she as we've
talked about a bit in here will have a
role both on policy personnel
and outreach and certainly have a seat
at the table uh i believe there's still
ongoing litigation
on this uh specific case so i would
i wouldn't expect that would be
something that a white house official
would weigh into
while there's a doj ongoing
consideration or ongoing litigation
is that why that issue was absent from
the slave executive actions that the
president took
if there's ongoing litigation that's
typically a factor but i'm happy
to check with you if there is anything
additional on this issue
going back thanks jen uh three foreign
policy questions on yemen press
uh the president president biden's envoy
to yemen
uh tim linderking just testified as
congress just now and he said that he
doesn't believe that iran
is helpful in ending the crisis in yemen
which he considered as a priority in his
administration
is this a topic that you guys gonna
raise in vienna
uh through your partners european
partners
i believe that the conversations in
vienna which are ongoing as you know
are focused primarily on uh the nuclear
file and uh where how we can get to a
point of having
uh compliance uh me meeting compliance
obligations i should say
on all sides so there are a lot of
channels we work through but i
uh my expectation is that those will
focus on that specific issue
talking about vienna uh western
diplomats indicating that the
negotiation seems to be going through
successfully
going halfway through as they say and
they believe that maybe you need two
more rounds to reach some kind of
agreement is this your understanding
and what what kind of agreement is it
just to go back to the
agreement itself i mean the previous one
in 2015.
well i can say that for the past few
weeks the us delegation led by special
envoy rob malley
has been exploring concrete approaches
concerning the steps both iran and the
united states
would need to take to return to the
mutual to mutual compliance and while
the discussions have been thorough
and thoughtful if indirect and we've
shared some ideas we still expect there
to be
a path forward so i don't i don't think
we're in a position to set
uh ambitious goals like a conclusion in
10 weeks two weeks at this point
and finally former secretary of state
mike pompeo
just had the press conference with the
republican study group
at capitol hill and he basically want to
introduce a legislation called
maximum pressure act does this
complicate your efforts now
do you see it as an interference do you
see it as
helping you and putting pressure on iran
to come back to the negotiation table
well i don't clearly have all the
details yet on what the legislation is
he's proposing but i would say broadly
speaking
our view is that diplomacy should be uh
in the lead
that the former administration uh pulled
out of the iran
uh deal which led us to a point where we
had
far less visibility uh into what
the in what was happening on the ground
in iran um
it certainly uh did not make us safer
and so
i don't know what's in his legislation
but it's i think it's safe to say we
have a very different approach
to the sanctions basically he would be
opposed to lifting the sanctions i don't
think we've indicated uh
we're speeding we're moving toward that
but we're having a discussion about
uh how to meet compliance obligations on
all sides and we certainly believe that
moving towards a diplomatic path forward
is
in the interest of the united states and
the global community
go ahead saturday is the armenian
genocide remembrance day uh adam shetton
a
group of 500 bipartisan lawmakers sent a
letter to the president
today asking him to follow through on
his commitment to be made as a candidate
will the president be following through
on his commitment and will it be coming
by saturday
with the latest remembrance sure i
expect we will have more to say about
remembrance day on saturday um but i
don't have anything to get ahead of that
at this point in time
okay thank you everyone
you